en este vídeo voy a crear una marca de
ropa en siete días sin ningún tipo de
inversión y esto lo vamos a hacer
gracias a una cosa que se llama print on
the Mandy son unas empresas que lo que
nos permiten es poner nuestros propios
diseños en sus productos y así vamos a
poder vender nuestra propia marca de
ropa sin ningún tipo de inversión en mi
caso voy a utilizar printful por aquí
podemos ver el primer diseño y como
podéis ver aquí el nombre de la marca es
el inglés sería como trabajar duro que
se utiliza mucho en todo el mundo del
emprendimiento bueno ya estamos a
domingo como podéis ver por aquí Así que
si venimos a las ventas totales nos
aparece que hemos saturado 209.93 euros
Así que entramos en algo importante es
que si os fijáis el precio que nosotros
nos cuesta enviar este producto va a
depender en función del fallo de
residencia de esta persona por ejemplo
si hacemos clic de esta persona nos
aparece que el subtotal
Ni más ni menos que 11,99 ya que este
personaje está en México y es un envío
bastante largo Así que el total del
coste son 27,19 y sacamos películas
y Nosotros hemos tenido el 27 Así que
nuestro beneficio son cinco con 61 Así
ha sido preparar un Excel para ver el
beneficio real detrás de todo esto nos
parece que el beneficio total es de
56,78 dólares americanos Y esto es lo
que hemos conseguido ganar en una semana
con cero inversión creando nuestra
propia marca